let's get into it uh the the players not
saying screw you to the teams as phase
two of the offseason program
began
most of the accounts that we have seen
reflect that a very high percentage of
players have shown up for what is the
first portion of on-field off-season
workouts phase one
strength and conditioning phase two
on-field instruction phase three
organized team activities an annoying
eight-syllable phrase for football
practice so
yesterday
everything i saw
high percentage of turnout for the teams
but you know one thing that i think the
nfl players association should start
doing
publicize chris the situations where
teams have made
concessions i saw yesterday stephen
holder of the athletic pointing out that
the colts yeah right got rid of the
mandatory minicamp
reduced the offseason program the
remainder of it to two weeks the bears
got rid of a week of otas these are
these are victories
that the union needs to be pointing out
because there's a lot of people out
there looking at this saying
why have you guys fought this battle you
can't win you can't win guys are going
to show up they're going to get their
work in that you want james situation
guts everything you're trying to do
they're scoring
concessions one team at a time
they need to be celebrating it and they
need to be hoping that what the colts
and bears are doing
something that other teams may do as
well so it's time for them to kick in
the pr machine and get the word out as
to the progress they're making with some
of these teams yeah they're not the
greatest at that i mean first off i'm
not shocked to see like you know the the
amount of guys we saw in facilities
yesterday right 70 80 percent attendance
you kind of hear throughout the league
that type of number yeah higher than
that 70 or 80 total players when you're
looking at 90 so it's higher than 70
yeah sure 90s the max sure sure so i
mean either way i'm not shocked to see
that number despite all the talk and
everything like that leading up to this
and the nflpa stance you know it's it's
it's too many there's just every player
like we've talked about they're gonna
have that moment where it's like wait uh
okay it's a week away from phase two do
i need to go in there and they're gonna
sit there or look at themselves in the
mirror and just go through everything
basically that we've said like are you a
star on the team are you just guaranteed
to be a starter and have a lockdown spot
on the roster and other than like we've
we've discussed other than four or five
superstars everybody else is like
i'm not sure um there is a guy right
behind me that's pretty good so you know
again who will be there who will be
there exactly right and who will be
there and be getting in the good graces
of my coaches as well where you know
again these coaches i mean they're not
going to play the lesser player to a
certain extent but like we've talked
about if it's close
the tie is going to go to the guy who's
there you know that wasn't the hostage
that was the volunteer so i i wasn't
surprised to see that and you're right
mike about your your statement
the nfl nflpa
they need to do a better job of
publicizing all their victories and a
lot of different things i mean yes i
think they can be better in that
department you're right i mean we're
seeing nfl organizations
like
i mean bend you don't ever see that for
the players
that's unbelievable they're compromising
so i do i think that's big news in the
nfl world and it shows we're on to a new
way of life in the nfl
and and that is something that we need
to praise because yeah
this was an uphill battle this was a
losing fight for the union going in
because collectively this isn't the time
to try to get the owners to make
concessions you had two opportunities
last year with the new cba that was
finalized in march and then they
basically had to rip up the cba at least
for 2020 and 2021 and replace it with
something that would cover pro football
in a pandemic and that was an occasion
to negotiate and then even earlier this
year when they figured out the salary
cap number that's another opportunity to
negotiate i thought hey you know why are
you guys launching this basically
it's not really a wildcat strike but it
kind of is you're flexing your muscles
and you're withholding services and
you're fully within your rights but what
leverage do you really have what
occasion do you really have to force a
global change and they may not
but they're forcing change
one team
at a time
and so maybe this is a multi-year
endeavor
and maybe at some point
the teams that have made some of these
changes and have gone on to be
successful in an environment with 17
regular season games that will become
the norm other teams will copy that and
i think that's going to be the litmus
test going forward yeah the teams that
reduce the offseason program versus the
ones that i don't i know if the teams
that reduce
are healthier
more successful that's going to be the
argument for more to do it now if it
goes the other way it's going to be
harder to get this to spread yes and i
mean that that to me is it will be a
huge tipping point you're right a year
or two of this
to see you know
which way is right which way is the
correct way you know me you've heard my
argument you know i i do think there is
something about being on the field
emulating a game you know not going like
oh we're on the field for only 45
minutes and we're off and we're fresh
that's great but a game's longer than 45
minutes and there's moments of sitting
around and it's listening to a national
anthem and tv timeouts and things like
that you gotta you gotta emulate that so
that's gonna be something like
definitely to watch for it those numbers
will tell us a lot i think the other
thing mike that's kind of interesting
here is it's like
uh and and maybe this is to the future
to what you're talking about a little
here too i mean i'm just surprised it's
kind of happening individually you know
it's it's like
one team at a time i always thought this
type of move would be you know under the
umbrella of all 32 but the fact that
you're seeing like personal negotiations
between
player reps
and you know gm's and coaches and
organizations to figure out a schedule
that makes sense for that football team
you know i can get behind that that's
the wave of the future maybe the wave of
the future the wave of the future what
movie i don't know if you'll remember
not sure
i don't remember all right sorry yeah
sorry what is it what is it leonardo
dicaprio the airplane movie when he's uh
you know the the rich guy that's uh
makes howard hughes yes thank you very
much yes sir
but but i found that interesting sorry
to change the subject totally there that
was a totally off base um but yeah i
thought i thought that was that's not
the first time it's happened it's not
but independence won't be the last today
individual negotiations mike though like
we're used to i was shocked by that when
i saw that i was like wait what teams
are cutting their own deals here uh i i
i never expected that
that's what tom brady encouraged when he
participated in the conference call that
was held now 11 days ago where all
players it was 4 p.m eastern on a friday
all players were invited i'd love to
know how many actually were involved but
i'm told by someone who was on that call
brady did a great job spoke well
and
set forth this objective of negotiating
directly with the teams now some scoff
to that and said why do we have a union
if you want the players to negotiate
individually with the teams there's no
reason for reunion if we're on our own
but i think at this time whether this
was part of a grand plan or just kind of
accidentally unfolded this way
the way to get these teams to bend a
little bit
was to
threaten to withhold services in the
off-season because they have the right
to do it in just enough stayed away from
just enough teams to get their attention
and i also think part of it is
the teams
looking at what happened last year
factoring in the reality that they've
got 17 regular season games that they're
going to want to keep their players
healthy for and
those teams the 14 of them that make it
to the playoffs are going to want to
keep their players healthy beyond that
they don't want the tank to hit e
at week 18. they want
to still have some gas in it when they
get to the wild card round division
around conference championship super
bowl ideally for two teams but
i i i like the fact that it's happening
and again
so much of this is about messaging and
the union has taken a beating from most
in the media who look at this and say
you can't win why are you doing this
guys are going to show up it makes no
sense you're putting guys at risk of not
getting paid case in point juwan james
so
they need to and i feel like at times
there's a reluctance by the union
to
to pump
its own
merit and to thump its own chest and
toot its own horn and like the people
who understand it they'll figure it out
and those are the ones we care about i
still think you have to be willing to
play the pr game and you're willing you
have to be willing to stand up and say
hey quit criticizing us we got this and
jc tretter did a little bit of that
yesterday chris in an item that was
posted at the union website i i
you know there was some stuff in there i
didn't disagree with like trying to
blame the media for part of this i i and
and the line was this for the small
number of players who choose not to
volunteer their time the media writes
articles questioning whether they are
team players or some kind of locker room
problem that doesn't happen very much
that really doesn't i mean the pressure
on players to show up comes from coaches
fundamentally and primarily the media is
saying so and so is not there he's not a
team player and you know that that may
be part of the pressure that the coach
is trying to exert through the public
relations aspect but i i think that the
main reason players show up is they want
to keep their coaches happy and like you
said
but for
that handful of guys who are secure in
their starting jobs not just their jobs
but they're starting jobs
it's very easy to make the argument for
everyone else that they need to be there
and and so kudos to the union
for finding a way to turn what appeared
to be a certain defeat
into a string of victories and i want to
know i've asked the union give me the
whole list of teams that have been of
teams that have that have revised their
off-season program you know the headline
at espn bears have 70 players show up
buried farther in the item
bears have agreed to get rid of a week
of otas bears have agreed to make the
practices less intense that needs to be
as
as prevalent and as conspicuous
as the attendance rate they're there
because
the bears have agreed to bend and i
think that the union's next job is to
make a much bigger deal of that and to
post an item from jc treader listing all
the teams that have said
we're willing to ask you to do less if
that'll get you to show yeah i i get you
that i mean i get you there i think that
is a positive for the nfl pa no doubt
about that you know and well i i guess
where i'm just interested to see is
where it goes individually you know
again i get back into like the type of
players on each team and all of that
where
i mean
really
i have a hard time thinking anybody's
going to talk to bill belichick and
negotiate him down for like
less practice time hey bill we're you
know we're thinking we want to do less
okay even though we haven't been doing
that much already this off season i just
don't see how that goes down maybe he
makes concessions a little bit about
fixing the schedule to make it more
accommodating as far as days and people
like things like that but that's where i
think it's you know another part of this
test going forward like you said is
gonna be
watching these teams that you know do
have full attendance do have a full
slate of otas and the full threshold of
phase one two and three and everything
like that to see where that goes but i
would think there's a handful of teams
where certain players are just not gonna
feel comfortable about going to their
head coach or their gm and going
let me have this conversation that's a
gutsy conversation when you become that
player rep that is known to be
a pain in the butt right really pro
player and always in the coaches office
letting them know what's the union and
hey there's these rules and you know
talking to the union about things that
the teams are doing listen the coaches
they know they don't like that that's
where it's scary too it's scary they'll
hold it against you
they will and then the next team that
wants to sign you as a free agent
they'll know too because that coaching
staff will tell you well yeah he's a
good player but
man he's
he's a handful as far as all the union
stuff and all that man we always had to
deal with them and that'll turn teams
away too so it's a very careful dance at
a political game here with all this
stuff
and that's why it's important for the
superstars to get involved in this
effort because they're the ones who are
immune at least for now
from getting any type of an adverse
reaction from the head coach and you
know the cults are going to shut it down
next week
next week that's before memorial day and
they're going to go until late july with
guys left to their own devices i think
that's part of this too you need to be
able to trust guys to take care of
themselves in the two months between the
end of the offseason program and the
start of training camp and you also have
to be able to trust the guys when they
are away from the structure yes of a
team are not going to find themselves in
any type of trouble because that that
used to be a much more significant
problem for the nfl but as clumsy as it
was as ill-advised as it was as awkward
as it was
the ray rice situation from 2014 the
aftermath of that with greg hardy and
adrian peterson that got the message
through to a lot of players about
staying out of trouble when they're not
part of that team so we'll see we'll see
how the cults do
between memorial day and late july and
if their players show up in shape and
ready to go then and and they do well
this year yeah right that may be the
kind of thing that that spreads to other
teams mike
one more thing can i just add one more
thing on that just sure i just i wonder
with this just because i remember when i
first got in the nfl like mike shanahan
and the broncos in their prime right
they they went to a little bit of a
phase there where
they let their players kind of have off
a little bit in the month of june and
they would have otas in early july i
don't know if you remember that maybe it
was it was very odd they were one of the
only teams that like early july those
first 10 12 days they would do otas and
then break for like 10 days and come
back for training camp
i wonder if we'll start to see certain
changings of the schedule like this
you know because of what you said like
hey the colts thing where coaches are
going to be like i just i'm not
comfortable with the fact that my guys
aren't here for two months and then all
sudden we hit the ground running and
doing that
i wonder if it'll make the coaches
change their approach a little too sorry
about that i had i had a conversation
exactly along those lines with someone
on saturday about the reality that they
need to take a look at the off-season
calendar and they need to maybe cluster
these workouts closer in time to
training right so
you don't have that long period where
it's shut down and guys potentially fall
out of shape but
here's where
the real world gets in the way yeah
people still want their four to six
weeks off
from the management side right coaching
staff very wrong
folks at the union who run the show
there they want mid-june to end of july
shut down so they can go have their
vacations and do their things that's
that's a human reality sure if you're
sputtering you never really have that
extended break where you can just get
away from it so
uh it's gonna take a lot
to bring back what the broncos were
doing where you have you know around the
fourth of july everyone's called back
together because the coaches want to get
away they do you're right they get away
the season's so intense they need that
time off
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports